Jim Carrey is getting serious about Will
Smith's Oscars slap not since the La La
Land and Moonlight best picture mix up
in 2017 has there been so much talk
about the Academy Awards but while that
mix-up briefly confused the Best Picture
Winner 2022's Oscars disaster is
overshadowing the year's big winner
entirely it was Coda by the way
as almost everyone is well aware by now
Smith unexpectedly slapped best
documentary feature presenter Chris Rock
after the comedian took to the stage at
the 94th Academy Awards Smith's
encounter with rock came after the comic
made a joke about Jada Pinkett Smith's
hair which was shaved following her hair
loss related to alopecia a topic which
she has been open about on social media
in the days following the awards
ceremony the amount of takes and
opinions about the incident seemed
endless some people said they understood
Smith's actions While others condemned
his Brazen act of violence the King
Richard actor has since issued a formal
apology to rock but some of Smith's
Hollywood Piers aren't so quick to
forgive him Sonic the Hedgehog 2 Star
Jim Carrey spoke with Gail King on CBS
mornings and condemned the public
reaction to Will Smith's altercation
with Chris Rock namely he did not
approve of the audience giving the I Am
Legend actor a standing ovation after
winning his award
I was sickened I was sickened by the
standing ovation
I felt like Hollywood is just spineless
on Mass
in general Kerry believes there is no
excuse for Smith to have gotten physical
regardless of whatever jokes rock may
have been making as such the actor's
opinion about the entirety of the Dolby
Theater applauding Smith for his best
actor win however Monumental it may have
been for Smith professionally was not
kind Carrie also mentioned that if he
was on the receiving end of Smith's slap
he wouldn't be quick to forgive in fact
he claims that he would have promptly
announced a lawsuit against Smith for
200 million dollars because that video
is going to be there forever it's going
to be ubiquitous
you know that insult is
going to last a very long time while
Kerry claims he has nothing personal
against Smith he was saddened and
dismayed that Smith's anger got the best
of him speaking on behalf of all of the
Oscar winners whose stories were
diminished by Smith's actions he said it
cast a shadow over everyone's Shining
Moment last night it was a selfish
moment Carrie's comments elicited their
own responses with many chiming in with
their thoughts on his opinion Justice
Smith has his fair share of both
Defenders and critics alike responses to
Carrie have been more or less evenly
divided as well filmmaker Andy ostroy
the director of the 2021 documentary
Adrian shared a link to an article about
Carrie's statement and said I'm with Jim
Carrey animator gabrillo natevich
meanwhile wrote in a reply to a video
clip of Carrie's response watched this
this morning and totally agree with Jim
Carrey Comics have a right to make bad
jokes without fear of being assaulted on
the other side of the fence are users
like writer Michael Chao who retweeted
an article about Carrie's opinion and
added I love Jim Carrey but like there's
a whole documentary about him being a
menace on set can't draw these lines
buddy other users took it upon
themselves to attack Jim Carrey online
posting instances from throughout his
life and career that they found to be
objectionable including the time he
kissed Alicia Silverstone on stage while
accepting an MTV video music award in
1997. whether you agree with Carrie's
comments or not one thing seems clear
anyone who wants to weigh in on Will
Smith's slap had better be prepared to
become part of the story check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell so you don't miss a
single one foreign